[Music]
this was a tea dance designed to feel
like the 50s a time when this was in the
charts
[Music]
and when the queen came to the throne i
went with a friend we didn't have a
television of our own but everybody in
the street
went to one house
where they had hired a television for
the day
just to watch the queen
among barbara wall and her friends there
is much affection and admiration for
their monarch linda bodel feels very
lucky to have met the queen in the 80s
when linda was working in a primary
school and this little reception child
when the queen went through to her
classroom got up out of the chair and
went over to the queen
and she said where's your crown mom
and the queen said i just wear my crown
for state occasions she said this is a
special occasion but it's not a state
occasion and she was just so so happy
everyone was welcome on the dance floor
as long as you could doci doe or at
least try to and of course there was
plenty of cake
what do you think of the queen
i like
the queen
and
i like all of her hats
nine-year-old poppy chapman came with
her aunt patricia chapman a fan of
william and kate
i think they're quite modern they seem
to be listening to the change to what's
happening in the world in terms of
various social issues
which has not necessarily been the case
as far as i know
they came to honour the queen but
perhaps more importantly it was also a
chance to be together
some of the people celebrating and
socializing here today are care home
residents who've spent much of the past
two years unable to see family or
friends
this afternoon they got to dance with
waltzing in their wheelchairs
we do try and get people out as often as
possible but coming to something like
this they've been able to look forward
to it get dressed up ready and having a
lovely time
this crown crocheted by staff at a local
care home was worn with pride
and the band had even written their own
song for the occasion
far from the mall and the pageantry at
the palace it was a wonderful tribute by
one small town to the queen of england
becky kochel sky news matlock